jo edwards et j'aurais bien
[Applaudissements]
puis on
c'est spécial
ouais
la piscine la piscine
il est super content il n'ya pas avoir
loana qui va venir dans un instant on
aura également evelyne thomas qui va
tenir mon chéri et il ya tous les autres
je vous le dis reste avec nous juste
pour voir la tête nos jours luc lemoine
sur la tête de ma mère
celui qui rigole pas c'est que il était
blond de la mort
[Applaudissements]
alors oui bon rester là donc on va
commencer avec avec avec avec afida
turner aller à l'école
[Applaudissements]
vous faites dans story on peu pas mal la
vraie musique de love story que tout le
monde connaît ou le de la tunisie
moderne voilà vers saint germain s'était
pas c'était pas mon émission mais obama
peut accueillir
faut y aller avec un voile à manger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
aucun mal
ah oui alors qu'il est coincé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
bon
jean vous pouvez voter pour le meilleur
déguisement je sais déjà qui sera pas
moi mais à mon avis je pense que ce sera
jean luc lemoine c'est pas mal
isabelle tepa balle si jamais les
parisiens voient les mails puis c'est
plutôt de tony tony de koh lanta
[Applaudissements]
bouazizi tony de koh lanta je suis le
meilleur ami de moundir et je peux te le
dire les femmes c'est comme les vitrines
comme tous ces très jolies je dors mais
comme toujours des fois tu es sacrément
déçu de ce que tu trouves dedans c'est
tout est faux c'est pas de vrais
moustache donc un honneur d oie le monde
de court
vous allez voir tout à l'heure il ya la
vraie loi naquit variées vous allez voir
la transformation
c'est ouf heureusement elle est
magnifique à battant na waie c'est
maintenant on à greg le millionnaire et
il le fait bien il le sait bien
greg le millionnaire améliorée
[Applaudissements]
eh ouais
[Musique]
comment comment tu te sens je me sens
toujours de porte ou tu tu veux arriver
dans ces bons gars c'est sûr oui merci
ok c'est bon d'être là n'ont pas ces
peintures de carrière à ceux ci à
wiggins et battant va recevoir ce type
[Applaudissements]
et la rigolade c'est comme être lui
dallas même te tais quand il faisait
titeuf en alsace mais c'est le même cas
il fait tout à fait tout le temps sam
hbcc vrais cheveux gillot tout cas vous
allez à fond à chaque fois voter pour le
meilleur déguisement et surtout ne
manquez pas sur luc lemoine quoi ce cas
là on est un petit désastre c'est quoi
bah c'est brandon de l'île
[Applaudissements]
oberson ma femme elle est où ma femme et
moi j'avais ces deux petites celui qui
se prend pour un comédien il a foutu
l'hérault le bâton tu vas prendre et tu
sénat recherche diana diana ma femme
j'ai un gros problème ait fait et vous
souhaite bien ah ouais je sais bravo
jean mi merci quel acteur et wii est le
meilleur pour la fin évidemment il a la
latitude on dit mais moi je sais même
pas qui c'est et en fait qu'il est
arrivé dans love tellement féminité qui
watts en fait c'est qu'ils le gardent
leur assez impressionnants ces mafieux
giuseppe
[Applaudissements]
ces neuf ans presque devant vous ce soir
et c'est dommage sans déconner mais ce n
est tout
j'en peux plus de cette date